ya toute la haine il ya tous les gens
qui sont enfin pour moi c'est il ya
toute la haine sur les réseaux sociaux
les gens en fait baïnes dès qu'il ya des
choses en défaut aux quelque chose
demain il s'acharne et du coup bah oui
il ya du racisme parce qu'il ya tous
enfin tout ce qu on dit pas en dans la
vie de tous les jours mais il exprime
par messager puis par les réseaux
sociaux parce que c'est plus ou moins
connus et ouais moi je suis influencé
aussi donc
par exemple moi je le vis avec instagram
ou coup j'ai des messages mais horribles
sur des faces sur mon physique des
façades et si des demandes de sexuel fin
des fois c'est juste difficile à un
cours à continuer quoi bon il ya des
gens qui se cachent en fait derrière des
faux comptes et qui se se pensent tout
permis en fait insulte les autres
gratuitement
et puis sans jamais être confronté en
fait c'est se cache donc
donc ouais c'est un peu gratuit facile
et puis les médias devraient faire les
réseaux sociaux devraient un peu contré
sa faim réprimandé ce genre de choses
moi je pense qu'il ya un vrai réel
racisme dans touita exemple je me suis
fait attaquer lorsque j'ai voulu émettre
un avis
par rapport à ce qui s'était passé aux
états unis avec le capitole est donc
très rapidement quelqu'un a réagi par le
fait que je puisse mettre en rapport
avec ce passé aussi avec d'autres
manifestions manifestations et des
meters et il disait que ont joué
beaucoup sur les émotions et la
victimisation et sauf que dans la
discussion j'essaie de mettre en avant
que en tant que personnes noires on
voulait être père c'est aussi comme un
être humain quoi alors moi je suis peu
sur les réseaux sociaux ça a été un
choix de les quitter et en effet quand
j'y étais j'ai eu un peu l'impression
que c'était un endroit où tout était
permis et vous l'avez ans humaine se pas
se lâcher et c'était vraiment des bonnes
soeurs de dépotoir en fait alors il ya
beaucoup de bonnes choses à prendre bien
sûr il faut toujours nuancé
mais la modération elles me semblent un
peu impossible parce que justement il ya
beaucoup trop de volume 2 de contenu et
de tweets et de poste et il ya beaucoup
de trop gros volumes pour modérer à
moins d'avoir des algorithmes et
justement après ça pose la question de
la censure en algorithmes ce qu'il est
le plus mais enfin le plus comment dire
de plus éclairés pour venir censurer des
humains je ne sais pas donc je dirais
que la modération allait elle est
nécessaire mais c'est très difficile de
l'imaginer en fait j'étais pas le
problème vient de tweeter en soi ou si
c'est un problème du fait qu'aujourd'hui
avec les réseaux sociaux ça donne la
possibilité aux gens de dire à peu près
tout ce qu'ils pensent tout le temps et
que je pense qu'en fait de façon globale
afin de polariser un peu le débat les
gens ont tendance à prendre des
positions très radicales et du coup a
pas forcément modérer leurs propos a
tweeté ou poster sur un réseau social de
façon très spontanée et sans modérée du
coup ça peut amener des commentaires
assez négatif qui peuvent être rapides
qui peuvent être très dur et ça on le
voit pas seulement sur twitter mais
aussi sur facebook sur sur d'autres
réseaux sociaux donc je sais pas si
c'est un problème de twitter en soi ou
six
et un problème de génération et de façon
dont on utilise les réseaux